when you tube mogul PewDiePie visited
the Late Show with Stephen Colbert in
October 2015 the host said I want to
thank the internet for allowing their
Emperor to be here for the that
obviously was a joke but if we had to
elect an Internet leader PewDiePie aka
Felix Kjellberg would certainly be in
the running the 26 year old native of
Sweden claims almost 50 million
subscribers on his YouTube channel the
most of anyone by miles while even your
grandparents might have confusedly heard
the name PewDiePie at least once how
many people really know his story here
are the gritty details behind YouTube's
happiest superstar a calling card
PewDiePie who found fame when he started
recording himself playing video games
gave himself is offed squealed nickname
preapre because of its resemblance to a
common sound effect found in those games
it's like any gamer I guess we all have
our nicknames
I would Nick pewdie because Pew like
lasers pew pew and I would yell out
beautiful whenever I did well in games
and people were just like for now just
got away with it Chell Burke's first
youtube channel launched in 2006 was
simply called pew die without the pie
the second syllable means exactly what
you think it means die as in characters
in the games die when the lasers come
out however he relaunched in 2010 after
losing his password to the first account
he added the pie part because well he
likes pie among other edible items
lots o loot 7.4 million dollars a year
seems like a lot of money for a college
dropout who worked at a hotdog stand to
make cash while playing video games in
fact 7.4 million dollars is a lot of
money for anyone to make but according
to some analysts it's nowhere near the
salary child Berg should be pulling
right now given his massive subscriber
base and the amount of ad revenue that
YouTube is pulling in from its video
plays experts say he's actually way
underpaid
even so Chell Berg rarely speaks about
his financial earnings from the site
because he says that he didn't get into
this business for the money I didn't
know you could be big yet well I know
people who were big at other type of
videos but there was no one big at
gaming and I didn't know you can make
money out of it so it was never like a
career that I just quit college to
pursue however he was still none too
pleased when YouTube's monetization
policy changed and he spoke out against
the company's decision if you don't know
what happened basically YouTube started
on monetization people's videos without
any notice parental approval before he
made it big online child bucks parents
weren't so keen on the idea of him
making a living by playing video games
they were both highly esteemed
executives in Sweden at the time and
seemed to hope he'd follow in their own
footsteps by sending him to Chalmers
University of Technology for industrial
economics but the corporate lifestyle
simply wasn't for him orally after I
quit college and so I had to get a job
and I took whatever job I could get
which was to work in a hotdog stand but
now that he's proven the worth of this
business his family seems to have come
around his mother and sister have both
made appearances on his YouTube channel
although his dad still seems a bit
camera shy the pro army the term bro has
all kinds of negative meathead
connotations here in the United States
but Kjellberg uses it a lot hail Sai Gon
bros here's going to press okay asking
for us some of his followers have begun
to live up to the connotation when other
youtubers play a game that PewDiePie has
already covered the bro army sometimes
comes after them in force for copying
the virtual leader PewDiePie himself
responded by posting a video mocking his
own fans and disabling comments on his
own uploads for a while PewDiePie Lantry
pissed as harsh as the pros can be and
as much flack as PewDiePie has gotten
for making millions he and his fans have
done a lot of good Kjellberg and the bro
army have already raised over six
hundred and thirty thousand dollars for
Save the Children over four hundred and
forty six thousand dollars for charity
water
and tens of thousands for other
organizations putting all those together
we have reached over 1 million dollars
towards charities how freakin that is ah
I can't what I can
PewDiePie is cutie pie Chell bugs
romance with girlfriend Marcia is a
fairy tale for the digital age
in 2011 the young Italian woman became
familiar with beauty's work through some
friends and became taken with him and
wrote him a fan email it didn't take
long for him to respond and then fly out
to Italy for a real-life date within a
year marzia moved to Sweden and started
a YouTube channel of her own called
cutiepiemarzia the to bounce back to
Italy for a while before settling in
England with their two pugs Edgar and
Maya
not a bad journey for a video game
playing hot dog salesman thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and don't forget to check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to